[Music]
thank you
a beautiful Sunday morning to you all
thank you so much for joining us eight
news now coverage of the Vegas strong 5K
as so many folks continue their healing
process now as we mark five years since
one October I'm Heather Mills I'm Nathan
turnendum and you know Heather for a lot
of folks a part of the healing process
has been running and so here we are with
the fifth annual Vegas strong 5K and
just a quick programming note Heather I
know we got a lot of Raiders fans that
are tuning in for the Raiders now
program don't worry it will Air it is
just going to be on at 8 30 this morning
so this half hour show will be over at 8
30 then the Raiders now now uh Sherry
sweats is the host in the MC she just
headed over to the start line but first
you know who else we have this morning
Heather we have our very own tasty
Fernandez and he's out there somewhere
where are you JC what's happening
hey Nate hey Heather I am at the start
line if everyone's lined up here at the
race itself is about to start in five
minutes and over the years I covered a
lot of 5Ks and there's I'll tell you
what there's a different energy about it
this morning there's a connective energy
I mean everyone has a connection to one
October and I have someone I want to
talk to here this morning her name is
Candace and Candace is in from
California and you're running for
someone's very special who are you
running for today yes I'm running for my
cousin Christiana Duarte and she was one
of the 58 victims that day tell us a
little bit more about your about your
cousin why you're running today my
cousin was amazing she was 22 years old
and full of life laughter she loved
country music she loved to sing dance
and and she was just an amazing person
her smile was contagious and this is uh
very special too because you have your
family back in California and they're
doing the Run virtually exactly exactly
the time we are virtually at her
favorite spot Redondo Beach California
so
we're all connected we're together well
Candace thank you so much for joining us
today I know your family here you're
gonna run it means the world to us that
you're out here today and just you know
Las Vegas loves you and you always have
our support thank you so much thank you
Candace I appreciate it guys there's so
many people out here running Nicole you
come over here as well and how do we
look the race is about the starting
we're spinning around there the races
just started so there goes the runners
this is the 5K it is it is a special
morning it starts with the 5K the
runners the run-up to Las Vegas
Boulevard make a left a total of three
miles and they are off so I also have
Nicole with me here and Nicole you have
a lot of friends that were out there on
one October so what does it mean to you
to be out here today yeah it really
means a lot for me to be here I know a
lot of people in our community were
really negatively impacted by this event
and this tragedy
um and so I'm part of Farmers Insurance
and I think it's a good opportunity for
us to give back to many of our customers
and employees that were also negatively
impacted and you have a group of friends
out here so you're doing the run so good
luck to you today and then real fast too
look I got this guy over here you talk
about dedication come on over here what
is your name how you doing Giovanni
Hernandez and you are running in your
gear today yes sir so why did you come
out here for this race today uh most
importantly just Community Support I
mean obviously the unfortunate event
that happened October 1st there's any
light that came out of it was just the
community support and the love and so so
I'm here running in my gear making sure
that I'm acclimated for any Hazard that
might arise around here that's
dedication this is Vegas strong right
here the runners are running you go
running and you're uh your your gear
there and thank you so much I want to
send it back to you Nate and Heather
boy I think that's really incredible JC
you know to hear the the phrase the
Vegas strong it goes such beyond our
community you had Candace who's talking
about her family and friends in
California and we know how much this
impacts people all across the country
and they're here today I mean more than
2 000 people out here reading which is
amazing including uh most folks from Las
Vegas but we have folks from many other
states I understand we have some Runners
from Canada who are with us today it is
an incredible event it just kicked off
now uh we know that Sherry was very busy
uh welcoming folks and being the MC ever
since the very first Vegas strong 5K
Sherry this race has grown how are you
doing over there
we're doing great we're right in the
middle of the crowd check this out
everybody they are ready ready for a
wonderful wonderful morning everybody is
Vegas strong thank you guys for being
here where are you from where are you
from
Suffolk Virginia Virginia
where are you from Henderson biggest
Streeter Illinois uh Illinois Illinois
where are you from Atlanta Georgia
Atlanta Georgia Georgia oh my God
Illinois Houston Texas oh my goodness
from everywhere
it is amazing and the street is still
full you guys they're still going past
you they're still going through the
start line oh the spirits are high
Everybody's Got Love friendship this is
definitely the road to Healing you
betcha good morning hi you guys it is so
great to see you thank you for being
here Battle Born you know it good
morning so all the the funds raised from
the Vegas strong 5K five years running
now it goes to victims funds it goes to
the children of the victim's family and
it goes for Education Cynthia Gainey is
the founder of just run and she's the
founder and director of this event she
has raised so much money let's take a
look at those scholarships where the
money goes
just seven weeks after the one October
shooting the first Vegas strong 5K hit
the pavement raising money for those
still reeling with pain and loss and now
five years strong the event has become
an annual reunion people want to be here
they want to come together and Remember
Las Vegas local and organizer Cynthia
Gainey uses her running event company
just run to bring thousands together
each October to run and walk the road to
Healing this year registrations are from
across the country and Canada and as far
away as Europe people kept saying we
want this to continue every year every
year and I said I will continue to put
it on as long as people want it 100 of
the proceeds go to victims funds and
scholarship programs for Las Vegas
students like Maggie Louie now a junior
at UNLV I think it's just part of your
own
passion to like save people Louie is
studying to become a doctor she says her
scholarship alleviates a lot of the
financial burden for her to become a
first responder so she can be part of a
positive change you see that more people
are caring about each other in a way
that's like how are you doing like are
you okay and I think the community is
more united in that way we see these
Scholarships in combination with all the
other services that are happening across
our community as one of the ways that we
can come together and heal and remember
what happened on one October Kirsten
Seer is president of the public
Education Foundation which Awards
various scholarships funded since the
2017 tragedy she says events like the
Vegas strong 5K help Empower our young
people to build a stronger community and
never forget and certainly we're seeing
that in the essays from our students
they're still feeling this and it hasn't
gone away and it probably shouldn't have
gone away we need to we need to remember
it we need to continue to talk about it
and recover together I will naturally
become a part of Vegas strong
and I hope to be able to spread that
message to other people as well we just
continue to do this and everybody's
going to come together and whether you
know somebody or not just come out
um participate and you will feel it
you'll feel the support you'll feel the
love Sherry swensk 8 News Now
okay
a really just truly magical event that
goes to so many wonderful things and the
energy as you just saw with Sherry it's
vibrant it's alive people are excited to
be here and happy to be here and to
share that love with our community so
we've got much more coming up as the
runners and Walkers continue to make
their way around the race course yes and
it's really you never know how someone
else's story may work its way into yours
as part of the healing process this is
eight news now live coverage of the
Vegas strong 5K